You've stayed in a relationship for that long,
there's a couple things happening in your brain.
And I feel like if you understood this,
that'll make it easier for you to leave.
Not talking to you like you're stupid,
I'm talking to you like I fucking care, okay?
There's this thing called the sunken cost fallacy,
and it's the idea. We're like,
well, fuck, I've already spent 10,
15 years, I might as well stay.
Like, that's kind of what happens at,
you know, you're one too.
You're like, well,
it's been. It's only been a year or two,
you know, I don't wanna give all that up.
Let me, like, keep trying.
And then you keep trying for one or two more years,
and then you're like,
well, fuck, it's been four or five years,
you know,
let me see if things can change, maybe,
you know, and you continue.
And that's one of the ways you get to 15 years.
So at a certain point you need to say,
it doesn't. I am just continuing to,
you know, pour water in a bucket with an.
With an empty bottom,
you know what I mean?
You have to reconcile the sunken costalis and realize, okay,
it's only. It's been 15 years.
Do I want it to be 20?
You know what I mean?
You gotta start making that good in your head,
cause this is really just a mind game.
It's mind over matter.
Like, you can do it,
Like, you've done hard things,
you can do this.
The other big mental game that is going on is change.
Your brain doesn't like, change.
Like, this is science.
I'm not talking about feelings,
I'm talking about fucking science in your brain.
Your brain just doesn't like, change anything different.
You know, the path of least resistance.
I'm already here.
It's our. This is how we do things.
I know what life is like.
Like this. I don't got to figure shit out.
Like, we got plans,
we always go in the summertime,
blah, blah, blah.
You know, you got this fucking routine that you're used to.
So your brain is just gonna automatically be like,
oh, yucky, I don't wanna make new neural pathways,
I don't wanna do that.
Cause that's what your brains gonna have to do,
is gonna have to figure a lot of shit out.
But I feel like once you know those two things,
and then you really examine your feelings
and then you really think about what do.
Okay, here's another big one to really think about.
Like, what are you waiting for?
Because the end of this is death,
you know what I mean?
Like, you give him another 5,
10 year, who knows what's gonna happen?
The end. What are you waiting for?
There's no like, finish line.
There's nothing,
you know what I mean?
It's like the more you stay,
the closer to death you are.
And then like, the less Energy.
You're gonna have to, like,
do shit. So, like. Hmm.
You know what I mean?
When you start to just, like,
logically, like,
take your feelings away from it.
We gotta learn how to, like,
separate thought and feeling so that you can make a fucking decision,
because you got it all jumbled up right now.